in the last week of the Israeli election
campaign a visual reminder to voters of
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu's
pledge to annex every illegal Israeli
settlement in the occupied West Bank
Netanyahu was joined by US ambassador
David Friedman and the rest of the joint
American Israeli Committee he chairs
mapping out exactly where the Trump
White House would recognize permanent
Israeli sovereignty unreported syllable
the mapping is on its way in order to
allow the imposing of the Israeli law on
these territories and later getting
American recognition nonetheless it
isn't quite what Netanyahu promised in
Washington a month ago he said he'd
begin annexation before the election
then the White House put the brakes on
it's complicated his bid for supporters
of far-right parties in places like
efrat an illegal settlement near
Bethlehem anticipation and excitement
and the disappointment and suspense
they haven't influenced the polls at the
moment into such a level that I can say
this has been the game changer instead
Netanyahu's been focusing on settlement
construction around East Jerusalem
announcing thousands of new housing
units in areas that would further
undermine the notion of a territorial
unified Palestinian state this is a
dangerous policy and we consider this an
act of
destroying the peace process there are
also plenty of Israelis who believe
annexation doesn't serve what they
consider the Jewish state that it could
make a bi-national state eventually a
majority Palestinian one more likely I
think they might have overreached
because by talking about and mixing all
the settlements this really terrifies
the one half of Israel that has
understood the demographic danger to
Zionism of non separation from most of
the Palestinians so I don't think he's
gonna get new votes from the left this
way but after three consecutive
campaigns most minds are made up the
game is more about motivating turnout
than persuading voters to shift
allegiance even the announcement of
Netanyahu's corruption trial date it
starts just two weeks after the election
appears not to have harmed him in fact
the poll suggests Netanyahu has
overtaken his rival Benny Gant's
although not by a margin that would give
him a majority coalition in Parliament
in the end the imminent annexation of
places like this has become one issue
among many in this campaign with
Netanyahu everywhere all the time
talking about everything from security
to diplomacy to the coronavirus but
should he win or should he be in charge
of another caretaker administration
after another inconclusive election his
campaign promise on annexation could
become very real hairy for said al
Jazeera in the occupied West Bank